there's a ship it's the only guy not
much man just sitting in here kicking it
it's for [ __ ] freezin here we're just
[ __ ] on Kalen how he's big you know
since you guys are doing a show together
now and and that's gonna take up the
majority of the internets time because
that's what people want to see is you -
I think it should just be me and here by
myself you two are doing a show this
guy's not even [ __ ] here anymore yeah
I just be me sitting in this thing by
myself with chin and cat just he
wouldn't be a bad ghost yeah he's a
great guy yeah but the property the
producer of Rome gets jealous rook of
the year cattle yearly job the chassis
that continuing the belt you like that
what was that movie where the kid had
the [ __ ] up arm played for the Cubs
and tossed it out it's recent ads rookie
Jim Abbott monkey but loving know he had
one arm bra yeah tours rope no this kid
was tore it off bow for a clean off yeah
yeah tug of war accident yeah I haven't
do one of the 60 or 70 probably best
one-armed people of all what's up what's
up yeah Kalin gets jealous bro yeah he
texted me are both you I'd watch him
said that he said I'm really tired of
you guys taken over my show it's my show
and I said it's not your show it's it's
all of our show it's a community show
yeah
the fighter and the kids it's called
although Theo and I talked about that on
his show you guys got a written the kid
kid is a weird thing to say on who now
and then what you were telling in this
client in this guy no and you know what
I told rivals I still brought our
animals yeah and there's you know kids
choose just on the table ya know it's
creepy for sure and we have kids toys up
there I get it creepy here's the thing
though I told Brian when I first met him
he was hey I'm Brian the kikiyaon yo
excuse me who gives you that name is
that's just what they call me you know
that's cool then we got to know each
other dude the name kid doesn't make
sense cuz you're old as [ __ ] he goes I
know onset I saw a movie one time that
he referred to Robert De Niro sona's the
kid so he just took you know a Robert
Redford
he's you know Callens from cows the same
age as Robert Redford the same age same
generation really yeah yeah he call him
Robbie they knew he knew Bob is Robbie
Robbie poet Callan just took nicknamed
himself I don't know but we know Bryan
well enough to know nobody calls him the
kit I've never
no one's ever called him the kit never
someone called him that I'm sure
probably I've heard people say well
people call him Papa yeah somebody
called him Papa so he got it he's gonna
FaceTime the other day with a couple of
kids they called him dad that make sense
how many kids you think he has seven no
three yeah
I picked you in a Ford Taurus like a 94
Ford Taurus and just jamming out to this
smoking a cigarette headed to Vegas yeah
how would to see you right now
[ __ ] yeah and look right here this the
best part though he is good damn dude
that's pretty good what'd he say he said
the lyrics are amazing what he's saying
slip away he's talking about a woman
who's with another man and he's jealous
and he says can you slip away just for a
moment can I ask you there's got a
[ __ ] huge yes but you have to love
who is too is the first time I heard
yeah there's really good guys you would
have to appear she appreciate that era
of music like I Love Boat on my father
loves Motown he left Carolina Beach
Music so I love [ __ ] I love this [ __ ]
dude like Otis Redding like Backstreet
Boys or train or drink to me you seem
like a Death Cab for Cutie trained no
dog I'm into Motown but what do I like
that's new okay here because people make
fun of me that one was [ __ ] good I'll
give you that that was nice I like do i
stroking for me i like funk and solan
yeah yeah yeah you like Bruno Mars he's
very good he's so telling he's so good
but I just it's just like a lot of it's
too light or to shoot I'm okay get a
Taylor Swift guy no dude I can't read
your bro I'm missing here you're missing
by a mile
all right let me look at one on some of
the stuff in here here we go ready here
we go there's a little Lil Wayne a
little bit a little wheezy in here
Andrew Bird Chicago artists never heard
of cunning linguist switch is a hip-hop
group uh what else would you know TV on
the radio I like them yeah uh yeah but I
like mute Ludovico Einaudi who's a who
is a classical pianist bro
I am diverse you are
I'm diverse dude dude hit the Beatles
Van Morrison never heard of him back Big
Boy
shout out dude nas I like everything on
if it's good I like it but you don't
like anything new or current it sounds
like you don't like the new [ __ ] I mean
I like new look what I knew what like
pop music like Takashi 6-9 little pump
I don't like cashing to 6 I don't like
guys who do that stuff that he does with
this hair and all that [ __ ] it's too
much he's a grown up dude you're a grown
up cut that cut that [ __ ] childish
[ __ ] out that's fair rainbow bro cut
it out you a Kanye West fan I I love I
love Kanye's music regardless of his
political views I can separate the
artist in the person I know people are
so mad about [ __ ] Kanye in the mag at
yeah I [ __ ] I like his music get the
[ __ ] out of here
I love labor registration was a great
album so was I mean every album I love
everything I like his old [ __ ] a lot and
I like some of his new [ __ ] to me too
but who
Oh whose new rap that I like um I think
uh uh Oh Machine Gun Kelly guy no I'm
just off here you're throwing so many
[ __ ] bad
I like often I like I like Pusha T I
thought his album was phenomenal okay do
you know push your team I dunno pusher
thing uh push her T I'm sure I know mr.
Fogerty I'm familiar with a pusher I
know the push push but I love Motown I
love that era I think funk and soul that
were birthed from like from Motown from
loud you're lucky counts not here right
now he would give you a history lesson
on Motown but I love that [ __ ] I love
that [ __ ] you'd only people on line said
it I look like Callens kid though people
like you're gonna be caroling in ten
years fifteen twenty I go first of all
I'm 35 Callens the inverse plus ten
correct he's 63 I'm never gonna look
like that guy okay
ever never I've class and dignity and
sexiness and there's an heir to me that
guys and girls sometimes but mostly guys
go those guys kind of a babe I like this
I don't like Taylor Swift stuff I don't
put it on but I know she's good at it
yeah what she does she's gonna I don't
I'm saying that's plenty people that I'm
like I'm never I'm not gonna be like
[ __ ] maroon 5 the other night I just
I stopped I never gonna put him on I'm
never gonna turn that music on the other
night I took myself a little edible and
I watched [ __ ] an entire concert lot I
think it was live from I was high
live from England and it was Backstreet
Boys and New Kids on the Block and it
was two hours long and you watch it all
of it dude if you need if you need to
hang out with somebody just call me I'll
come over I found it so fascinating that
these grown men are still on tour and
they're doing the dance moves together
how fascinated day would be to find out
that this other grown man is high in an
edible watching their tour and
fascinated by just going I want and I
start seeing him because I know how much
money like touring acts make well they
make their money break it down and I
wonder how much they make while yeah I'm
gonna get bum I got real high and
started looking into it you'd be
surprised but they do a lot of dates you
know big arenas still and the entire
arena all all chicks all chicks see not
me I want all dudes oh my god Oh all
dudes
I want all dudes and one girl one girl
in the far back do you have a suite I'll
have to clear this past weekend it is
strange I'm like you dumb [ __ ] I don't
you know what you know you know what you
know what's are funny about [ __ ]
hecklers nobody nobody likes them and
for some reason they still keep popping
the [ __ ] up
like I like trolls on the internet yeah
it's as if I don't think it's everybody
knows how annoying it is and that's some
reason somebody keeps going I'm gonna do
that to [ __ ] do it
but no one's usually usually that closer
they'll never celebrate it they're never
sober
no one's ever like ooh you beat that
comic good yeah that's true I've never
seen that work out for him ever yeah but
you know but but I think the thing is
like people also go to comedy shows that
don't really love comedy they just go
cuz it's a night out yeah and they get
drunk yeah yeah and then they lose
themself and they get into this thing
where they're like [ __ ] we're just
having fun man and [ __ ] you and you're
like it's not fun though you're ruining
it for every yeah yeah no one thinks
it's [ __ ] cool but you know and I'm
gonna piss on you from that I wouldn't
heckle you though dudes don't heckle you
mmm I've had it before
in Australia and st. Louis cuz then you
could be like hey just come up here and
we'll fight yeah that's not funny
the crowd goes yeah but then you go I'm
just kid
hahaha but I will fight you hahahahaha
I will fight you then it's funny again
that's kind of funny when you see my
back Ripple and I pull myself up like a
champ like a chimp 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift